this next story is one of those it's
been a serious show
this is one of those funny stories that
is really more about donald trump's
fragility than it is about anything else
donald trump has suddenly backed out of
throwing out a first pitch
at an upcoming new york yankees baseball
game now
there are three different reasons why
and you can say that it's all three or
just one or two
you know take your pick first of all i
believe trump
is worried that he's going to really
screw up the first pitch and he's going
to be again
a an embarrassing laughing stock trump
is claiming that he's going to be too
busy to do it he tweeted yesterday quote
because of my strong focus on the china
virus including scheduled meetings on
vaccines
our economy and much else i won't be
able to be in new york to throw up the
opening pitch for the yankees on august
15th
we will make it later in the season so
this is not
credible this is the guy who just golfed
for the 282nd day during his presidency
he says he's gonna be too busy working
now to throw out a pitch which takes
five minutes he's so
fragile i get he has to travel to new
york he's so fragile he's afraid of what
will be a disastrous pitch
so that's number one now i want to be
clear
this is not about wait a second david
you complain trump doesn't do any work
and now you complain that he's going to
be working instead of throwing out a
pitch
you're being a hypocrite no trump's just
lying again
we know trump doesn't skip things that
he thinks will make him look good or
that are fun for him
because he has to work he's golfed 282
different days during his presidency
trump is skipping this because
especially after his skills playing
catch were ridiculed last week
when he tossed the ball around with
former yankee mariano rivera
he knows he could come up with an
embarrassing first pitch and it would be
really bad
he is scared someone might realize maybe
trump isn't the alpha male he makes
himself out to be but
here's the thing if you don't think
that's the reason why trump isn't going
to do it there's another reason which is
trump doesn't want to get
booed we're talking about new york city
trump was getting brutally booed at
sporting events
before coronavirus he was not losing to
biden by 10
and he was getting destroyed when he
went to sporting events with just brutal
boos
he was going to get obliterated with
booze at yankee stadium so
it's the pitch itself that he'd likely
mess up plus getting brutally booed at
yankee stadium and it being repeated on
tv for hours
but if you don't like either of those
explanations
entire baseball teams have been kneeling
during the national anthem in the early
days of this new major league baseball
season
it's another reason trump doesn't want
to be there for that
because again trump would be out there
with his hand over his heart
trying to remember the words the
national anthem while
all or most of the players would be
kneeling in another
direct rebuke of donald trump so
those pick which of these or all three
of these reasons
of course trump is bailing on throwing
out the first pitch and anyway
imagine claiming you're too busy to
throw out a pitch
the day after retweeting as he did on
saturday
a picture of himself and former nfl
quarterback
brett favre playing golf as 77
000 new coronavirus cases had been
announced the previous day in the united
states
it just doesn't pass the sniff test
that donald trump is not doing this
because he's too busy
he's just too fragile for me you know we
need a stronger president no i'm not
talking
physically i'm talking intellectually
i'm talking
emotionally personality wise trump is
just too fragile for me
i'm going to be voting for joe biden in
november
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience
25 percent off your first order
this has been a game changer for me this
is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes awesome there's a variety of
flavors
i have blood orange which i love you can
also get grapefruit
and lime a lot of us don't even realize
when we're dehydrated a lot of the time
and it's become
a really a great part of my daily
routine if i'm
under hydrated i'm affected physically
i'm affected mentally and i think
you never fully understand this until
you use hydrant for the first time
i get a great a boost of energy when i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video